10.000 83 euro und 47 cent so viel
erhält ein bundestagsabgeordneter pro
monat
darüber hinaus darf er nebentätigkeiten
ausüben das ist durchaus legal
dafür gibt es gesetze die das juristisch
regeln und dafür gibt es auch so was wie
einen politischen instinkt oder man
könnte auch das schöne wort vom anstand
bemühen da aber wie wir erleben ist
einiges durcheinandergeraten und genau
das ist unser thema heute und damit
herzlich willkommen mir bei zdf heute
live die masken affäre ist das thema das
nicht nur die union erschüttert es geht
um gier und korruption
aber natürlich auch um jede menge
verdruss darüber wollen wir reden mit
dem mitglied des bundestages thomas
jarzombek von der cdu gespräche mit
lobbycontrol wir wollen aber natürlich
auch eure meinung hören und wie immer
könnt ihr schreiben an die jetzt gleich
eingeblendete adresse an zdf heute -
live at zdf de und dann werden eure
fragen weitergegeben
zum beispiel thomas jarzombek um 18 uhr
lief die frist aus die unionsfraktion
hatte alle abgeordneten dazu
aufgefordert schriftlich stellung zu
beziehen
ob sie sich bereichert haben sprich
verdient haben
ancona maßnahmen beziehungsweise an
dieser pandemie in irgendeiner form
verdient haben darüber wollen wir jetzt
zunächst erst mal reden was dabei
herausgekommen ist und live zugeschaltet
aus unserem hauptstadtstudio ist mehr
mathis feldhoff hallo mathis wir haben
vorhin schon das ergebnis gehört das ist
nicht alle wegzunehmen
also man darf es vorweg nehmen an der
stelle es fiel eindeutig aus wie genau
sind 100 prozent der abgeordneten die
diese erklärung diese ehrenerklärung die
die fraktionsführung von ihren
abgeordneten gefordert hat
unterschrieben haben das ist ein
erstaunlicher wert weil wir das zdf
haben ja auch gefragt wir haben die
gleichen abgeordneten gefragt und bis
heute mittag ungefähr 14 uhr waren es
ungefähr 82 prozent die sich uns
gegenüber erklären wollten dazu muss man
allerdings sagen
das ist auch ein paar gab die sagten wir
werden uns bei der fraktion gegenüber
erklären aber nicht gegenüber dem zdf
das ist ihr gutes recht
eine erste frage hier kommt schon von
christian drop ziehen score glaube ich
offen sprechen den namen halbwegs
richtig aus ist das ein schlechter
scherz schreibt er da wer von denen gibt
denn jetzt freiwillig zu so etwas
gemacht zu haben das ist ja lächerlich
willkommen im kasperletheater
deutschland und dann denke ich matthias
hört man schon den verdruss raus denen
das alles auslöst geht es da eigentlich
wirklich nur noch um schadensbegrenzung
oder ist das schon mehr
es ist schon mehr als nur
schadensbegrenzung das ist ja kein
kleines skandälchen
das ist sozusagen das liegt an den
grundfesten unserer demokratie an dem
vertrauen in die politik es wird
sozusagen mit dieser affären dieser drei
abgeordnete jetzt aufgefallen sind ja
der eindruck erweckt dass sie sozusagen
politik käuflich und das ist natürlich
ein riesen problem oder noch anders
herum noch wie schlimmer ein mandat
dafür gibt dass man gewählt ist und vom
volk gewählt ist würde da sozusagen
versilbert oder vergoldet
je nachdem wie viel geld mehr bekommen
hat bundespräsident steinmeier nannte
heute das verhalten schäbig und
schändlich es sei gift für die
demokratie wie gefährlich ist denn diese
affäre tatsächlich nicht nur für die
union
das hat man an der reaktion auf der
opposition und auch des
koalitionspartners spd gesagt gesehen in
den letzten tagen da gab es natürlich
den hinweis und die aufforderung die
union müsse das jetzt aufklären und
transparenz und die union habe sich in
manchen fragen was du das lobby register
und ähnliche fragen angeht nicht
besonders kooperativ verhalten in den
letzten jahren aber richtig scharfe
angriffe gab es nicht weil sich am ende
nicht alle sicher sind ob es nicht auch
in den eigenen reihen den einen oder
anderen gibt der da die hand aufgehalten
hat das war auch der union ja nicht klar
dass es solche leute gegeben hat also es
ist schon eine sache der gesamten
politik die auch die gesamte politik am
ende ausbügeln muss natürlich leidet die
union jetzt zum beispiel den
landtagswahlen am kommenden sonntag
sicher am stärksten darunter das ist
glaube ich brauche ja kein wahrsager
sein dass es nicht auf der hand aber
auch alle anderen parteien befürchten
damit natürlich in mitleidenschaft
geraten so in zugzwang zu kommen und
auch ja wieso man sagen in mithaftung
genommen zu werden
wir sprechen gleich weiter schauen aber
erst mal gerade um welche fälle ist denn
da genau geht und führen uns die noch
mal vor augen
fünfundzwanzigster februar der bundestag
hebt die immunität des csu abgeordneten
georg nüßlein auf kurz darauf durchsucht
die polizei seine wohnungen und büros
der vorwurf bestechlichkeit nüßlein hat
staatliche aufträge für schutzmasken an
unternehmen vermittelt im gegenzug soll
seine firma 660 1000 euro vom
unternehmer thomas limberger erhalten
haben gegen beide und einen dritten
unternehmer wird ermittelt die agnes
klein ist aus der csu ausgetreten will
sein bundestagsmandat jedoch bis zum
ende der legislaturperiode behalten
der mannheimer cdu abgeordnete nikolas
löbel hat ebenfalls massen geschäfte
vermittelt
für den deal mit privatunternehmen bekam
labels firma 250.000 euro provision eine
nach dem marktüblichen bemessene
vergütung wie der abgeordnete mitteilt
dennoch räumt er fehler ein und gibt zu
er hätte sensible handeln müssen
am ende wird der druck zu groß lüben
legt sein mandat nieder
auch der thüringer cdu abgeordnete mag
hauptmann hat sein bundestagsmandat
niedergelegt
ihm wird vorgeworfen geld von
ausländischen regierungen angenommen zu
haben
unter anderem aus dem autoritären land
aserbaidschan hauptmann weiß die
korruptionsvorwürfe zurück wegen seiner
kontakte nach aserbaidschan steht auch
thomas bareiß parlamentarischer
staatssekretär im wirtschaftsministerium
unter druck dabei geht es um die
lieferung von beatmungsgeräten
auch er weiß die vorgeführt zurück
matthias ich denke ist es wichtig dass
man diese fälle und diese drei beispiele
auch auseinander hält gehen erstmal
durch gegen georg nüßlein von der csu
ermittelt die staatsanwaltschaft wurde
die immunität aufgehoben es gab
durchsuchungen möglicherweise eine
anklage
es gibt den anfangsverdacht der
bestechlichkeit der fall wiegt schwer da
ist man sich glaube ich einig ja es ist
wahrscheinlich auch der komplexeste fall
von einen 3
man muss sich das noch meine erinnerung
rufen georg nüßlein hatten masken
geschäft vermittelt oder
sagen unterstützt es geht um ein
massengeschäft der firma lomo tags mit
unter anderem dem der bundesregierung
dem bayerischen gesundheitsministerium
und wahrscheinlich einem dritten
bundesland dieses massengeschäft ist
vermittelt worden oder abgewickelt
worden über einen händler ein vermittler
der sitz in london und der hat um dieses
machten geschäft anzukurbeln damit dass
sozusagen auf dem stapel in den
ministerien ganz nach oben rutscht in
dieser schweren zeit im april mai juni
juli letzten jahres als es gar keine
masken auf dem deutschen markt gab hat
dieser vermittler georg nüßlein
engagiert damit er sozusagen seine
kontakte spielen dass der hat das auch
gemacht und zwar auf dem offiziellen
briefbogen des deutschen bundestages
hatte er für dieses geschäft mit der
domotex geworben und hat dann diesen
vermittler dem man in england eine
rechnung gestellt und zwar eine eine
liechtensteiner firma und dann wird es
langsam ein bisschen wild diese
verrechnung von 660.000 euro es bezahlt
wurden von einer firma die in saint
vincent in der karibik sitzt wieder über
eine liechtensteiner bank und weil herr
nüßlein halt ein sogenannter pep ist das
nennt man eine persönliche eine
besondere persönlichkeit ein
abgeordneter aus deutschland gibt es
eine rente pep informationen damit für
die finanzaufsicht in liechtenstein
aktiviert und regt eine mitteilung ist
diese informationen dann an die deutsche
finanzaufsicht gegangen die hat es an
die generalstaatsanwaltschaft gegeben
und so entstand dieser verdacht gehe um
georg gegen georg nüßlein
wie gesagt gehaben nüßlein ist
inzwischen von seinen ämtern in der
fraktion zurückgetreten aus der fraktion
ausgetreten ist aus der csu ausgetreten
nur nicht aus dem bundestag da will er
noch bis zum schluss mit namen auch das
hat durchaus ein geschmäckle und für
ärger gesorgt der zweite nikolaus löwe
von der cdu hat eingeräumt dass seine
firma 250.000 euro provision erhalten
hat das ist sicher verwerflich aber wenn
man ihm nicht mehr nachweisen kann nicht
unbedingt strafbar hier prüft die
staatsanwaltschaft und trotzdem war auch
da der aufschrei groß der druck ist
natürlich auch enorm das muss man sich
so vorstellen nikolas löbel
hat in mehreren mails an verschiedene
firmen seine dienste als vermittler
angeboten er habe kontakte zu einem
chinesischen konzern der masken
hersteller dieser kontakt sei offenbar
über seine abgeordnetentätigkeit als im
auswärtigen ausschuss auf den er sehr
stolz ist zustandegekommen dieser
kontaktmann ist zufällig mitglied des
chinesischen volkskongresses also ein
abgeordneter der kommunistischen partei
und der sei auch zuständig noch masken
produzent über diesen kontakt hat level
halt masken des eingriffs wedelt hat
dafür eine provision eingefordert hat er
gleich ende mails sozusagen angekündigt
wie viele er bei vertragsabschluss pro
gekaufter oder bestellter maske nimmt
das waren bis zu zwölf cent oder mehr
pro maske und da geht es ja dann um
tausende von masken dann am ende
summiert sich das auf 250.000 euro möbel
hat das zwischendurch als marktgerecht
bezeichnet was da als er gefordert hat
am ende war der druck so unglaublich
groß auch unter unter anderem auch vom 9
cdu parteichef laschet der form im
hintergrund zum rücktritt und ja auch
zum austritt von möbel aus der cdu
gewirkt hat der dritte im bunde westmark
hauptmann auch da gibt es den verdacht
dass er geld aus aserbaidschan genommen
hat er bestreitet das aber ist dennoch
zurückgetreten wenn man diese drei fälle
mal zusammen nimmt man das alles in
allem welches bild gibt die union in
diesem super war ja da gerade ab was nur
von deutlich sagen ein bild der
korruption das trifft natürlich auf die
genannte fraktion zu das ist ja klar das
würde auch niemand behaupten dass die
fraktion der union korrupt ist aber
diese drei fälle und noch ein paar
andere man darf nur erinnern an die
fälle fischer auch cdu abgeordneter oder
karin strenz cdu abgeordnete die beide
ermittlungsverfahren über sich ergehen
lassen musste der sich ergehen lassen
müssen wegen ihrer kontakte zum beispiel
auch nach aserbaidschan und bücher
geldflüsse das ist alles nicht schön das
wirft ein zeigt ein bild sozusagen als
wäre die politik käuflich auch wenn es
nur einzelne sind mathis vielen dank für
den moment besprechen ganz zum schluss
der sendung noch mal aber danke für den
augenblick hören wir rein in die
fraktion
ich hab's eingangs schon gesagt uns
sprechen jetzt mit thomas jarzombek
von der cdu einen schönen guten abend
nahmen
es ist zwar keine sehr einfallsreiche
frage aber ich glaube sie muss dennoch
gestellt werden wie ist die stimmung
heute in der fraktion
die stimmung ist nicht gut ja weil am
ende haben hier kollegen man kann es
nicht anders formulieren scheiße gebaut
und das reißt uns alle momentan und
mitunter in unserem ansehen und viele
glauben jetzt dass wir ein üblicher
modus bei bundestagsabgeordneten und das
sind schwarze schafe die aller unserer
reputation beschädigen und ich glaube
auch nicht nur die unserer fraktion
sondern auch der anderen fraktionen ist
das ein scherbenhaufen kann man das so
sagen ich glaube nicht dass das ein
scherbenhaufen ist weil wir haben 250
abgeordneten im deutschen bundestag und
nicht so viele kollegen die sich in bein
ausreißen für die menschen in ihrem
wahlkreis die versuchen deutschland
besser zu machen und die hier auch
wirklich ein ehrliches ansinnen dabei
haben und ich bin davon überzeugt dass
sich das auf die dauer auch durchsetzen
wird aber in dieser woche wurde diese
fälle jetzt halt tatsächlich in dieser
3er serie aufgetreten sind sieht das
natürlich alles andere als gut aus und
insofern ist bei uns die stimmung geben
auch einfach schlecht punkt nehmen sie
uns mal mit sozusagen in die fraktion
wie wird denn da gesprochen ist ja klar
dass man vor der kamera sich hinstellt
so wie sie das jetzt dankenswerterweise
auch tun und die dinge beim namen
benennt aber wenn man da untereinander
und miteinander spricht und dann auch in
die zukunft schaut wieviel falten haben
sie dann auf die stirn ich habe ehrlich
gesagt nicht so viele falten auf der
stirn
es ist total unrealistisch zu glauben
das ist nie wieder schwarze schafe geben
wird wie gesagt wir haben 250
abgeordnete im deutschen bundestag die
drei fälle die sie jetzt gerade auch
beleuchtet haben die sind wirklich
unfassbar
und ich glaube da wird niemand die hand
ins feuer legen können dass es da nicht
noch irgendwo in weiteren fall gibt aber
entscheidend ist das mussten einzelne
fälle sein ich weiß von vielen kollegen
mit denen man auch spricht wo man dann
halt eben auch ganz klare einschätzungen
hört und wo natürlich jeder auch schon
meine erlebnisse hatte und sagte da
wollte man etwas spenden habe ich sagen
mach das mal lieber nicht und so weiter
und so fort ja ein kollege der mehr
sagte hätte seinem steuerberater
wenn du dich fragst ob man es machen
kann dann mache es nicht ja wir wissen
abgeordneter stehen hier unter
besonderer beobachtung ich finde das ist
auch richtig weil wir natürlich hier
auch eben an der spitze der demokratie
stehen die muss man gerecht werden und
ich sehe viele die wirklich sich alle
mühe geben das dann auch zu tun
schau mal hier in unsere rückmeldungen
die wir bekommen auf youtube heißt es
von zitzewitz 7 in einer pandemie in so
einer situation die seit dem zweiten
weltkrieg nie wieder gegeben hat wird
das politisch nicht nur politisch
ausgenutzt und er schließt mit dem
schlichten appel
schämt euch bundespräsident steinmeier
hat ja heute gesprochen und er hat
gesagt es geht um sehr viel mehr als nur
individuelles fehlverhalten es geht um
das vertrauen in die integrität des
staates wie viel vertrauen hat die
unionsfraktion mit diesen drei
mitgliedern zerstört ja es ist ein
prinzip die gleiche frage sie gerade
schon gestellt haben
ich kann nur sagen im augenblick ist das
ist der vertrauensverlust sicherlich
groß und wir müssen jetzt daran arbeiten
das vertrauen wieder auch zurück zu
gewinnen und das muss jeder einzelne
auch vor ort in seinen wahlkreisen
machen ich glaube da kann man am besten
überzeugen aber auch eben durch gute
arbeit und eben auch dadurch dass solche
fälle verhindert werden und unsere
fraktion schlägt er jetzt auch ein zehn
punkte programm vor mit dem wir ja ganz
gezielt jetzt auch noch mal weitergehen
wollen weiter auch als das was bisher in
der politischen diskussion gewesen ist
ganz ausdrücklich zum beispiel jede form
von lobby ähnlichen tätigkeiten zu
verbieten unter strafe zu stellen und
hier auch gewinnabschöpfung
möglichkeiten entsprechend zu etablieren
ich glaube das wird im zweifelsfall auch
schwierig sein hier wirklich immer eine
rote linie und eine klare grenze zu
ziehen ist meine befürchtung und das
alles zu überprüfen und durchzusetzen
ich finde es aber das richtige signal
und ich glaube es doch ein überfälliger
schritt und dann geht es auch um fragen
beispielsweise wo kollegen also ich
glaube wer mit mit als selbstständiger
mit einer firma in den bundestag gewählt
wird
dass der dann seinen betrieb nicht
aufgibt weil er ja auch nicht weiß was
aber nach vier jahren wiedergewählt wird
das liegt glaube ich auf der hand meine
eigene biografie ist beispielsweise auch
genauso aber
kollegen die im mandat firmen gründen
und dann auch noch als unternehmenszweck
beratung oder ähnliches an geben wird
einer von den drei fällen
das finde ich dass das riecht ja schon
total merkwürdig und dass man so was
künftig nicht mehr akzeptiert das ist
absolut richtig und ich glaube dann
müssen jetzt auch handeln hören wir mal
was timo lange von lobbycontrol dazu zu
sagen hat seine frage bzw
sein statement ansehen ich würde nicht
sagen dass das ein problem dass
ausschließlich die union betrifft aber
man muss schon sagen dass gerade die
union durch ihre auch programmatische
nähe zur wirtschaft zu unternehmen und
auch die nähe viele abgeordnete zu zu
unternehmen das sieht man an den
zahlreichen nebentätigkeiten hier
besonders anfällig ist für für solche
sehr fragwürdigen vorgänge auch dass die
union insbesondere in den letzten 27
jahren eigentlich jede initiative hin
für mehr transparenz für strengere
regeln blockiert hat und abgelehnt hat
immer argumentiert hat die bestehenden
regeln würden ausreichten und während
auch gar nicht notwendig da jetzt noch
verbesserungen vorzunehmen und das feld
der union jetzt gerade gehörig auf die
füße
thomas jarzombek sie sind beauftragter
des wirtschaftsministeriums für digitale
wirtschaft start-ups und sie sind auch
koordinator für luft und raumfahrt
kommen sie der wirtschaft zu nahe
das muss man sich tatsächlich genau auch
eben immer fragen und ich glaube ganz
entscheidend ist dass man sich hier
nicht für einzelne unternehmen
einspannen lässt
und ganz entscheidend ist natürlich
darüber noch dass man hier selber kennen
die auch immer gearteten vorteilen
mitnimmt also ich war wirklich ehrlich
gesagt geschockt und unabhängig davon
als das moralisch völlig verwerflich
halte was kollegen da machen bin ich
auch überrascht
ganz ehrlich über die dämlichkeit weil
das mit informationsfreiheitsgesetz und
den pep und all den dingen die sie
vorher auch schon beleuchtet haben dass
das alles raus kommt heutzutage ist doch
vollkommen klar ist ja der staat habe
ich ja nur so viel wenn nicht sie
unterbreche dass sie wurden halt
erwischt aber es geht auch um etwas
anderes geht doch darum dass man es
nicht macht und das auch irgendwie
regeln aufgestellt werden dass klar ist
was gemacht werden davon gemacht werden
soll und was eben nicht und nicht nur
das nunmehrige wege findet sich nicht
erwischen zu lassen fast denen sie mich
bitte nicht falsch also das ist genau
das was ich damit sagen die dinge sind
ja und er sagt und es gibt ein regelwerk
und strafen und ganz offensichtlich
funktionieren die auch dafür braucht man
ja regeln und strafen auch als
abschreckung damit für alle klar ist das
machst du besser nicht mal ansonsten
wird es dir übel ergehen und das zeigt
dass zumindest die einige mechanismen
ganz offensichtlich funktioniert haben
und ich kann nur sagen ich finde es
moralisch ein totales noko sich hier wie
auch immer geartete geldliche oder auch
geldwerte oder was auch immer geartete
vorteile halt eben zu verschaffen von
vom dritten außerhalb eben des gewählten
spektrums der der politik und des
mandats lässt sich nur leider
vorschreiben das ist genau das problem
das ist ehrlich gesagt genau das problem
ich sagen auch bei der politiker war und
das ist in der tat so man sieht
natürlich auch bei manchen kollegen wenn
man sich jetzt auch anschaut von von
nicolas
oder hoffentlich kann man seinen
ehemaligen kollegen dass das ja dann am
ende sozusagen die spitze einer
entwicklung gewesen ist und das finde
ich ehrlich gesagt ist eine
verantwortung die wir alle in der partei
haben die werden wir mit reinen
regelwerken auch nicht lösen können das
halte ich für eine illusion aber bei den
fällen wo man schon sieht dass leute
irgendwie chrome unterwegs sind im
sozusagen klein war ich es bei loewe
schon gar nicht mehr so klein fand
da müssen klare stoppschilder gesetzt
werden und das ist die verantwortung die
wir jetzt in der cdu haben ich bin
selber cdu kreisvorsitzender in
düsseldorf über die ganzen jahre sieht
man natürlich auch immer wieder
irgendwelche fälle
und dann heißt es 80 jahre ist noch so
jung das ist noch so klein und wir haben
auch kleine dinge geahndet um damit
einfach auch zu zeigen das geht nicht
wehret den anfängen und das ist genau
das was jetzt halt eben auch konsequent
exekutiert werden muss sie sind aus
düsseldorf und stellen sich da morgen
auch in die fußgängerzone und wollen da
einen stand sozusagen beziehen und damit
auch positionen was befürchten sie da ja
ich befürchte da ehrlich gesagt gar nix
und so dicht machen
ich erwarte allerdings jetzt auch nicht
dass die menschen mit großer
begeisterung der morgen auftreten
sondern ich finde es ist wichtig dass
man als abgeordneter ich bin direkt
gewählter abgeordneter
dass man mitbekommt wie die menschen
denken über das was passiert und was ihr
auch von einem erwarten und auch noch
mal ganz konkret und das ist im
persönlichen gespräch immer noch was
anderes als das was man in der zeitung
liest was man im internet liest was man
aus der blase vielleicht auch der
eigenen partei hört oder aus dem
berliner raum und deshalb ist das ein
mechanismus den ich gerne an wände am
ende halt eben mich mit den menschen zu
unterhalten ich mache sonst auch schon
mal aus besucher in der spitze der
flüchtlingskrise habe ich das gemacht
und habe da ganz interessante
rückmeldung bekommen die auch anders
waren von stammwählern wirklich anders
auch waren als das was die eigenen
parteimitglieder denken und ich finde es
geht im übrigen auch darum flagge zu
zeigen dass man auch sagt ich mache mich
mit dem was diese kollegen gemacht haben
nicht gemein im gegenteil kritisierte
das deutlich und lass uns darüber reden
wie wir besser werden können und auch
vertrauen zurückgewinnen können sie
haben es vorhin schon angesprochen die
fraktionen von ihnen möchte jetzt so
einem zehn punkte plan aufstellen
gehen wir mal einige dieser punkte durch
wir schauen uns das glaube ich jetzt
hier in einer grafik mal an
da sind unter anderem die punkte das
bezahlt interessensvertretungen von
abgeordneten ganz verboten werden
aktienoptionen müssen offengelegt werden
es gibt keine abgeordneten spenden mehr
demnach und nebeneinkünfte ab 100.000
euro müssen und sollen angezeigt und
offengelegt werden
reicht das zumal jetzt schon klar ist
die spd geht gerade bei dem letzten
punkt nicht mit ich weiß nicht ob das
reicht das werden wir jetzt diskutieren
ich glaube das ist aber der richtige
aufschlag und am ende ist es natürlich
so dass jede partei und jede fraktion ja
auch andere biografien ihrer mitglieder
teilweise hat und man muss sagen dass
man wenn man mal auf die andere seite
der argumentation schaut dann ist es
natürlich so dass wir als union auch das
wichtig finden dass man am ende halt
eben nicht nur beamte in den parlamenten
sitzen hat sondern dass auch sich
selbstständige darin wiederfinden
landwirte das eingangs schon mal gesagt
menschen die jetzt für vier jahre im
bundestag nicht ihr lebenswerk veräußern
werden und da muss man halt eben gucken
ob das regelwerk dann so ist dass man
solche menschen halt eben auch noch für
die politik bekommt und ich bin nun
selber auch gesellschafter einer firma
gewesen noch mit zwei weiteren
gesellschaftern und in dem augenblick wo
deine vollständige transparenz
kundenlisten quasi öffentlich gemacht
werden auch noch mit einzelnen umsetzen
können sie sich natürlich vorstellen was
das für die konkurrierenden unternehmen
bedeutet und was dann die eigenen
mitgesellschafter dazu sagen wenn sowas
veröffentlicht wird das ist einfach die
andere seite die muss man halt auch
sehen und dann werden in zukunft wenn
man das sozusagen zur großmacht werden
dann ganz bestimmte berufsgruppen sagen
ich werde nicht mehr in die politik
gehen und ich glaube im parlament muss
den anspruch haben alle sichtweisen zu
vertreten
das ist ja nicht so dass ist ja alles
nachvollziehbar aber trotzdem hat sich
etwas verändert und ich glaube die
empörung kommt ja auch aus dem punkt
heraus dass man den eindruck hat alle
müssen zu machen alle müssen knapsen
alle müssen gucken wo sie bleiben und
andere nehmen 250.000 und nennen das
markt gerecht wenn ich jetzt hier lese
zum beispiel ihren bludau für hat via
youtube geschrieben immer dieses
ablenken der union das nervt die union
empfängt nicht umsonst 8
60 prozent aller spenden die im
bundestag öffentlich werden das sind
gefälligkeiten heißt es da und das ist
eines der beispiele die man hier nennen
kann
der punkt ist doch weniger dass man
irgendwie regeln aufstellt das hätte man
ja auch schon längst tun können sondern
der punkt ist doch glaube ich der dass
man irgendwie das gefühl verloren hat
dass da etwas abhanden gekommen ist was
jeder denkt dass man jedem sozusagen auf
der stirn ablesen kann
aber was für einige offensichtlich nicht
gilt das ist auch der punkt der so weh
tut ja und dafür sind die kollegen
herausgeflogen
die haben ganz offensichtlich das gefühl
verloren ja bei nikolas löbel wird
diesen satz habe ich unglaublich
aufgeregt
es ist ein totales no go da brauchen wir
nicht länger darüber zu reden
die frage ist wie kriegt man das problem
am ende halt eben in den griff und da
glaube ich ist es in der tat was ich
vorher auch schon mal gesagt habe dann
muss jeder vor ort wirklich daran
arbeiten das ist das einzige was helfen
wird solche fälle in zukunft zu
vermeiden
wir brauchen zusätzlich auch ein
regelwerk aber wir werden auch mit lobby
register und auch mit dem zehn punkte
programm werden wir nicht jeden dieser
fälle am ende komplett eliminieren
können und dann ist ja auch noch andere
beispiele gibt wir sprechen gleich
weiter wollen aber jetzt an der stelle
mal noch ein paar andere beispiele uns
kurz anschauen die die ins bild passen
sage ich mal
der junge cdu abgeordnete philipp am tor
steht in der kritik
er hat lobbyarbeit für das
us-unternehmen orgasmus intelligence
gemacht im gegenzug soll das unternehmen
reisen hotels und teures essen für den
politiker gezahlt haben außerdem bekam
der abgeordnete aktienoptionen und einen
direktorenposten bei der firma
ein verfahren wegen bestechlichkeit
gegen am tor wurde eingestellt viele
fragen sind aber noch offen
trotzdem hat die cdu mecklenburg
vorpommern philipp am tor zum
spitzenkandidaten für die kommende
bundestagswahl gemacht
auch gegen gesundheitsminister jetzt
sparen gibt es vorwürfe im letzten
oktober mitten in der pandemie hat der
minister ein spenden dinner in leipzig
besucht
am darauf folgenden tag wurde sparen
positiv auf corona getestet die höhe der
spenden soll genau bei 9.999 euro
gelegen haben
bei einem euro mehr hätte die cdu den
namen der spender veröffentlichen müssen
man muss dazu sagen da liegen die fälle
anders aber wie gesagt sie passen sie
passen insofern ins bild dass es mit
verdruss einhergeht ministerpräsident
961 schreibt via youtube wo ist das
jetzt ein größerer skandal als zum
beispiel am tor
da hat man einfach die füße still
gehalten und alles war vergessen was
sagen sie dazu
ich glaube philipp hat seine direkte
konsequenz gegeben nämlich er war ja
designierte landesvorsitzende cdu und
mecklenburg vorpommern und musste dann
von der kandidatur zurück treten und es
ist eben nicht geworden
also insofern hat seinen fahrverhalten
hier auch zu einer direkten konsequenz
geführt aber spitzenkandidat ist ja
schon
ja das ist natürlich jetzt auch ein jahr
später und insofern hat aber erstmal
eine konsequenz gegeben
und meines wissens nach ist das was er
gemacht hat offensichtlich alles
rechtens gewesen es ist nach meinem
dafürhalten alles andere als legitim
gewesen
dafür gab es eine politische strafe und
das ist der fall bei philip arthur bei
den spann übrigen ist das nicht ganz
richtig auch wenn sie einen euro mehr
gespendet hätten bei 10.000 euro der ist
auch nicht veröffentlichungspflichtig
gewesen
insofern verstehe ich ehrlich gesagt
auch nicht ganz genau wider was
geschrieben hat aber das ist noch ein
anderes thema wie meinen sie das
ja weil das natürlich ganz klar den
eindruck erweckt als wenn man hier
irgendwas verheimlichen wollte
naja jetzt lief das sagen wir mal mit
ihren spanischen glücklich und das hat
ja durchaus auch eingeräumt dass er
sagte und zumal es dann ja auch noch um
die frage ging ob er da eben auch seine
krone infektion bekommen hat von nachdem
er am gleichen tag übrigens hier im zdf
gesagt hatte bitte haltet euch von
irgendwelchen veranstaltung fern und war
dann selbst auf einer
ja ich glaube dazu hat er selber schon
alles passen gesagt ob man jetzt auch
nicht noch mal neu zu bewerten
das war keine geschickte aktion aber ich
glaube hier stehen auch viele leute
unter großem druck das muss man
ehrlicherweise auch sagen da werden auch
mal fehler gemacht und es ist so dass
gerade auch in dieser situation manche
auch wirklich 24 7 gearbeitet haben und
das sieht man auch bei uns sind gilt
übrigens auch verdammt bei uns im
wirtschaftsministerium sind viele die
noch am freitagabend um 23 uhr e mails
schreiben und und teilweise sonntags
morgens um zwei also in der zeit wird
wirklich große krise gestartet ist daran
die apparate wirklich auch
durchgearbeitet und da passieren eben
auch mal fehler
das sind natürlich keine dinge die auf
unsere unser image positiv einzahlen und
die ich gut oder richtig schön auf gar
keinen fall
naja fehler wie gesagt sind das eine
aber was man sozusagen daraus macht bzw
was eben herbeigeführt wird indem man
aktiv wird mit den beispielen die wir
vorhin auch genannt werden wenn es darum
geht geld zu verdienen oder eben auch
und dass er jetzt ein anderer fall als
als bei sparen das muss man auch
ausdrücklich dazu sagen wenn es eben um
korruption geht es da sind es ja nicht
nur fehler trotzdem noch mal die frage
ärgert es sie dass sie wie jetzt eben
auch hier und heute abend den kopf
hinhalten müssen für das fehlverhalten
anderer spaß macht das nicht also ganz
ehrlich würde ich lieber lego modell in
einem sohn bauen als jetzt hier heute
abend dazu rede und antwort zu stehen
aber das ist eben auch unsere aufgabe
und wir müssen der verantwortung gerecht
werden das hilft nur alles nichts am
ende ich komme doch auch zurückkamen
reden wir jetzt hier von drei fällen von
250 abgeordneten und ich finde es gut
dass mal brinkhaus und die
fraktionsführung da jetzt wirklich auch
durchgreifen und hier eine zero
tolerance strategie anwenden und das ist
das einzige was hilft wir brauchen jetzt
hier an der stelle auch einen klaren
reinigungsprozess und dass diese
kollegen die hier fehler nicht über
fehler gemacht haben sondern die ihr
moralisch verwerflich gehandelt haben
dass die jetzt nicht mehr mitglied
unserer partei und fraktion sind das ist
genau das richtige
und da muss entsprechend jetzt auch bei
georg nüßlein natürlich noch der
austritt aus dem bundestag erfolgen für
sowas habe ich auch überhaupt kein
verständnis und ich glaube auch nicht
dass ihm das persönlich hilft für all
die dinge die er in seinem leben noch
machen möchte
dass sich ihre fraktionschefs genötigt
sehen von allen eine erklärung
einzufordern die heute bis 18 uhr
abzugeben war
was macht das aus ihrer sicht deutlich
dass es misstrauen gibt oder dass es
gehörigen klärungsbedarf gibt oder wie
tief lässt das eigentlich blicken also
für mich ist das ein zeichen dass der
fraktionsvorsitzende es ernst meint und
sagt wir werden jetzt überall genau
hinschauen wir werden solche fälle
überhaupt nicht mehr dulden und wir
werden hier sehr konsequent durchgreifen
und ich glaube das war jetzt nicht nur
ich schick an alle einen brief und dann
ist für mich der fall erledigt sondern
wir haben ja erlebt in verschiedenen
fällen dass ralph brinkhaus hier auch
sehr ernsthaft mit den leuten geredet
hat und hier auch ganz klar gemacht hat
dass es hier überhaupt keine toleranz
gibt und das finde ich richtig das finde
ich gut und das unterstütze ich sehr
nachdrücklich frank beyer fragt via
facebook warum müssen abgeordnete
überhaupt nebentätigkeiten haben das
muss ruhen in der zeit ist seine
forderung das finde ich ist ehrlich
gesagt ein guter punkt
also ich jetzt mal aus meiner eigenen
biografie ich habe eine firma mit 12
teams ist das gegründet habe das über
zehn jahre betrieben und als ich dann in
den bundestag gewählt wurde habe ich
mich da natürlich beim man kann neben
dem bundestagsmandat nicht noch eine
ernsthafte unternehmerische tätigkeit
nachgehen ich weiß nicht wie so was
gehen soll und war noch eine zeitlang
mitglied in der geschäftsführung aber
natürlich nicht mehr so präsent wenn da
schnell raus gegangen und dann
irgendwann habe ich auch meine
gesellschaftsanteile verkauft allerdings
glaube ich dann in der dritten
wahlperiode weil man natürlich immer
sich mit der frage auseinandersetzt was
machst du denn wenn du nach vier jahren
oder nach acht jahren nicht mehr
wiedergewählt bist und wie kommt man
dann in den beruf wieder zurück und ich
glaube wenn ich kollegen sehe die
landwirte sind die vielleicht noch
anrufe geerbt haben und denen zweiter
oder dritter generation betreiben wo
noch die ganze familie mit da drin hängt
eben umso mehr und ich glaube man will
ja auch abgeordnete haben die auch ein
bisschen erfahrung aus dem realen leben
haben und auch beruflich schon mal was
gemacht haben was ich schwierig finde
ist dieses ganze thema mit den
vortragshonoraren und das ist keineswegs
ein thema unserer fraktion
also auch zum beispiel christian lendner
der da ja gerade einige forderungen
stellt mit sonderermittler hat da ja
auch eine sehr umfangreiche liste von
tätigkeiten
das finde ich ehrlich gesagt wenig
nachvollziehbar dass man solche honorare
nimmt das bezieht sich auch auf andere
tätigkeiten hat schon mal gesagt diese
beratungsgesellschaften und ähnliches
das geht überhaupt nicht auf solche
neugründungen im bereich der anwälte
glaube ich ein sehr schwieriges feld
weil diejenigen die sagen ich bleibe
noch in meiner kanzlei und macht
wenigstens noch hier und da man fallen
und nicht ganz 1 zu rosten in meinem
beruf ist es aber dann auch schwierig
herauszufinden was machen sie denn da
eigentlich ganz genau
aber da werden wir jetzt noch einmal
mehr hirn reinstecken müssen die man
auch gerade bei den juristen solche
fälle besser auseinander klangen sagen
kann denn hier darf es jetzt in der
zukunft wirklich keine dunklen ecken
mehr geben in dem man nicht mehr ganz
genau rein gucken kann und wo dann am
ende eben vielleicht doch honorare dafür
fließen das hier irgendeine politische
form der beratung stattfindet das finde
ich persönlich auch nicht akzeptabel
hören wir abschließend bevor wir zum
ende kommen nochmal timo lange von
lobbycontrol
die union muss jetzt ganz klar
konsequenzen daraus ziehen und das heißt
eben nicht nur über einzelfälle zu
sprechen sondern das problem ein stück
weit an der wurzel packen und das heißt
auch gesetzliche verschärfungen bei den
regeln für die abgeordneten da brauchen
wir mehr transparenz aber eben nicht nur
wir brauchen auch klare verbote etwa für
lobby tätigkeiten neben dem mandat die
union hat sich da lange gegen solche
regeln gesperrt hier scheint sich jetzt
langsam ein umdenken abzuzeichnen dass
muss jetzt aber auch wirklich konsequent
verfolgt werden und nicht wie wir sonst
auch oft beobachtet haben eigentlich
mehr ausgesessen werden ein solcher
skandal über einiges davon haben wir
schon gesprochen zum beispiel über den
zehn punkte transparenz plan den sie
jetzt mit der spd auf den weg bringen
wollen dass andere wiederum das lobby
register hat ewig gedauert bis sie sich
darauf verständigen anfang märz war es
dann soweit warum eigentlich so lange
und werden sie jetzt davon eingeholt
dass sie so lange gebraucht haben doch
die dinge die er gerade
getragen wurden die haben wir
angekündigt das wird jetzt machen ich
finde das persönlich auch richtig so und
was das lobbyregister betrifft haben wir
in dieser woche auch noch mal eine
verschärfung vorgenommen da geht es
jetzt zur abwechslung auch nicht immer
nur politiker sondern auch um die
beamten bis zu der ebene der sogenannten
unterabteilungsleiter sozusagen mittlere
führungsebene dann im ministerium müssen
dann künftig kontakte in seinem blog im
register eingetragen werden was der
dissenz war zwischen der spd und uns ist
der punkt von diesen sogenannten
exekutiven fußabdruck ich gebe zu ich
halte persönlich auch nicht viel davon
weil will am ende eines gesetzes steht
irgendwie eine liste von 30 verbänden
von keine ahnung dem bundesverband der
deutschen industrie bis hin am ende
vielleicht auch lobbycontrol greenpeace
oder was auch immer für ngo dann
entsteht der eindruck nicht die beamten
oder die politiker hätten das gesetz
gemacht sondern diese verbände und das
ist glaube ich ein falscher eindruck in
deutschland werden die gesetze in der
regel tatsächlich erstmal von den
beamten gemacht in den ministerien und
dann gehen sie ins parlament und werden
von den abgeordneten halt diskutiert
durchleuchtet überprüft und auch noch
mal verändert das kann man auch alles
nachlesen aber es ist nicht so dass hier
irgendwelche unternehmen oder verbände
oder ngo gesetzesvorlagen hineinschieben
ich glaube das würde auch den stolz der
beamten verletzten von denen ich sehr
sehr viele im laufe der jahre
kennengelernt habe diese intelligenz
sehr gut qualifiziert sind und wir haben
einen sehr hohen ethos
gesetzgebungsarbeit betragen alles
richtig und trotzdem hat es lange
gedauert bis es soweit war thomas
jarzombek letzte frage gibt es
eigentlich stellen sie das so fest haben
sie so ein gespür dafür jetzt ein
umdenken ein wirkliches umdenken in
ihrer fraktion wie gesagt nicht dass das
alle irgendwie schwarze schafe sind aber
die man wie man sozusagen auch denkt
damit umzugehen oder spüren sie vor
allem eine angst bei der nächsten wahl
abgestraft zu werden
also die bundestagswahl im september und
bis dahin gibt es noch eine menge
gelegenheiten zu zeigen was man eine
gute arbeit leisten kann das was man
jetzt machen
ich sehe in dem ganzen vor allem für uns
die chance die wir aber auch nutzen
müssen wirklich auch mit dem harten
besen durch zu kehren und zwar schon im
anfang und in den kleinen fällen das ist
das wo es drauf ankommt das geht auch
bei den ganzen nachwuchsleuten die wir
haben gute nachwuchstalente aber da muss
von anfang an schon klar sein dass man
dass es hier klare rote linien gibt und
wir die überschreitet der es dann raus
und das müssen wir jetzt konsequent
durchziehen das ist chance und
herausforderung in einem aber das ist
maßgeblich dafür dass auch in der
zukunft die cdu csu fraktion jedenfalls
in ihren übergroßen anteil mit seriösen
leuten bestückt ist du musst jetzt merkt
vielen dank für die zeit die sie heute
abend hatten und viel spaß hatte ich mal
und gutes gelingen bauen in der
fußgängerzone in düsseldorf danke für
den moment und damit kommen wir noch mal
abschließen wie schon gesagt zu mattes
fällt auf der das jetzt auch beobachtet
hat mathis du hast das vorhin schon mal
angedeutet aber trotzdem noch mal war
auch der name lehnt neun andere viel wie
reagieren denn eigentlich die anderen
parteien auf das was da gerade bei der
union passiert naja wie gab mit mit
vorsicht habe ich das gefühl weil sie
alle natürlich auch wissen dass sie
nicht alles sozusagen die weißen vögel
sind sondern das ist da durchaus auch
das eine oder andere schwarze schaf gibt
der spitzenreiter für nebenverdienste im
deutschen parlament ist nicht die unions
fraktion der spitzenreiter für
nebenverdienste ist die fdp fraktion
das muss man deutlich sagen aber
möglicherweise hat die fdp fraktion auch
gerade das problem dass sie natürlich
keine abgeordneten hat die sozusagen die
karriere von beamten zum
bundestagsabgeordneten gemacht haben
oder vom studenten über die mitarbeiter
in der landtagsfraktion direkt in die
bunten das bundestagsmandat sondern dass
da viele anwälte zum beispiel unterwegs
sind dass da viele menschen unterwegs
sind die auch eine eigene firma haben
das ist halt dann auch ein teil das
wasser zum berg geben beschrieben hat
sozusagen die realen welt eines
bundestagsabgeordneten
und da gilt dann
möglicherweise auch sagen ich will dich
soll ich sagen
der kompass ein bisschen geschäft bei
allen parteien
union und spd haben heute ja mal geredet
über diesen zehn punkte plan die spd hat
gesagt ja das ist ein guter ansatz da
kann man jetzt mal darüber reden dass es
gibt sicher nach schöpfungs bedarf aber
vor allen dingen hat die spd der union
signalisiert das geht nur mit allen
anderen oppositionsparteien zusammen das
machen wir nicht hier als große
koalition als einsam und alleine sondern
müssen alle parteien mit ins boot weil
es um halten und die gemeinsamen rechte
aller abgeordneten geht
wir haben vorhin von der bundestagswahl
gehört die ist noch eine weile hin aber
jetzt am sonntag übermorgen gibts schon
die ersten zwei landtagswahlen hier im
rheinland pfalz und auch in baden
württemberg gehst du davon aus dass nach
dieser wahl wenn je nachdem wie sie
ausgeht die ganze debatte noch eine neue
dynamik bekommt das hängt ein bisschen
davon ab ob sie natürlich ob es neue
fälle gibt ob es weitere beispiele gibt
entweder in sachen masken oder in sachen
honorare der mac hat gerade ein beispiel
also ein stichwort genannt oder im
bereich sozusagen unterstützung aus
fremden staaten wie wir es bei
aserbaidschan gesehen haben
also das ist ein bisschen schwer
vorauszusagen
wir werden glaube ich nach dieser wahl
der zu einigen eine debatte bekommen
darum wer wird den jetzt kanzlerkandidat
der union
und damit wird auch die frage gestellt
werden wer ist eigentlich schuld an
diesem schlechten wahlergebnis jetzt am
sonntag ist es armin laschet mit seiner
manchmal auch erklärungsbedürftigen
performance in sachen kroner pandemie
bekämpfung oder ist es sozusagen diese
masken affäre die sich konzentriert auf
drei abgeordneten inzwischen nicht mehr
mit der union sind da wird dann auch ein
bisschen schwarzer peter verteilt die
union wird versuchen das ganze auf diese
drei zu schieben im wesentlichen die
sind also schuld
ich glaube dass am ende doch ein
bisschen von allem alles das ergebnis
der union das kann man glaube ich
voraussagen wird nicht berühmt werden
vielleicht kommt sie mit einem schweren
blauen auge davon sage ich meinen namen
halbwegs blauen aber meine schweren
blauen auge weil viele wähler ja
wahrscheinlich briefwahl gemacht
und das im zweifel die einen wahlschein
längst abgegeben haben bevor diese drei
fälle aufgebraucht sind
mansfeld danke für diese einordnung live
am abend aus berlin
das war es für heute vielen dank für
eure aufmerksamkeit
die fragen die wir hatten gingen mehr
oder weniger alle in die gleiche
richtung aber ich denke wir haben
einiges gehört nicht nur von
lobbycontrol sondern eben auch von
thomas jarzombek der zumindest den mumm
hatte hier heute zu stehen und rede und
antwort zu stehen dafür noch mal vielen
dank danke euch für die aufmerksamkeit
kommt gut ins wochenende bis zum
nächsten mal